e
okay um good morning everybody please
take your seats we're going to get
started with our work session
bless you all right members please take
your
seats like to get
started okay um
don't have two of our sub right
representative Kenny would you please
would you please lead us in the Pledge
of Allegiance welcome to environment and
agriculture this
morning allegiance to the flag of the
United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
under God indivisible with liberty and
justice for all
thank you we're gonna begin this morning
with a work session on Two
Bills um I know we're waiting on
some uh final draft of the uh Amendment
for the architectural paint recycling so
why don't we talk about HB 1698 first
which is um relative to the use of
drones for the aerial application of
pesticides um I did have a copy of the
amendment um on the table there if
you're if you'd like it um but basically
what this amendment
does uh different than the amendment
that I presented when I brought the bill
to the committee last week is that now I
am pointing uh to on line five uh as you
have a copy in front of you uh that un
and aircraft as defined in RSA 422 colon
3 Roman numeral 30 and that one as
opposed to the one that I had before
which was I think
27 um points to the definition of
unmanned aircraft as opposed to small
unmanned aircraft uh the definition the
federal definition of small unmanned
aircraft had a um a weight limit of 55
pounds and I believe some of these um
drones that spray pesticides on crops
are a little bit heavier than that so uh
so as not to have a
problem um I I am now pointing it to the
correct RSA as well as Federal
definition for unmanned space uh
spacecraft
aircraft and
um so the this amendment to the original
Bill also um makes that that spraying
cannot happen above 20 ft above ground
level so uh and I checked with the uh
New Hampshire Farm Bureau and also the
agriculture commissioner and everybody
was all okay with that so this is the
amendment that I would be uh presenting
this afternoon when we exec the
bill I'm sorry this morning yes this
morning hopefully we'll be done done by
noon we can get out of here um you have
a comment representing kraton yeah yes
ma'am um I read through the amendment
and answered
uh three of my questions the first was
uh bringing it down to 20 feet and
spraying
down uh created actually less of a
footprint from a blowing perspective
than spraying up from the ground so
those two
aspects um and then
uh yeah and then the the third one was
just the weight they said they weigh up
to 400 pounds and this this accomplishes
that so I'm I'm good with this uh with
this bill with this amendment over
representative Bixby so um the uh there
was a person who was supposed to uh who
who is uh in the business of uh doing
contract spraying with drones uh from
New York State who is going to uh be
with us for our hearing last week but
got called back for a family emergency
uh so wasn't able to join us he did send
a letter and uh he indicated that the
changes that uh this current amendment
makes uh resolve all the issues that um
that he saw in terms of being able to um
get the proper permit in and uh uh and
to do the spraying in New Hampshire and
uh so I think that it's important to
know that the the people in the industry
feel that this is an appropriate
Amendment uh I would second uh what
representative kraton said about uh this
being uh the the Drone spraying being a
lower impact method of applying
pesticides than ground spraying uh
because uh it can be uh um more targeted
and it uh because the propellers
actually drive this the uh the spray
downward uh it it reduces the uh level
of drift uh in a way that you don't that
would be below what you get with a a
ground spraying rig representative ktoa
thank you madam chair um I believe that
this is a must pass bill for
agriculture um and as everyone said the
20 foot uh height is sufficient um the
other thing is is when you're down
spraying you're actually getting into
the plants better to better uh get
better uh
coverage um and this will actually help
agriculture across the state uh because
it'll help with reducing uh Capital
costs and um being able to Target things
a little bit better instead of just
doing an overspray of areas that don't
need
it represent
ger thank you madam chair and I also
wanted to uh say I fully support this
bill I appreciate Madam chair's uh
Amendment uh originally I it heard as I
think some of us did from from
beekeepers who had concerns but I was
glad to hear in the testimony uh that
the the issue around the neonix I guess
is what it's called right that that
isn't an issue we're talking about here
anyway but especially with the amendment
uh that Madam chair has offered to
reduce the height from 50 to 20 feet I
think um makes this an even better bill
it's important for our Farmers so I
definitely fully support the direction
it's going in
okay all right any other discussion
about the amendment or this bill or okay
I think we're good with that um so next
on our um discussion list this morning
for our work session is
the uh
1504 relative to architectural paint
recycling and I believe there is an
amendment uh on being printed as we
speak and I'd like uh representative
Murray to
elaborate thank you madam chair um yes
so those of you does everybody have a
copy of what I had handed out which is
uh yes thank you um so what we would
like to see here is that um this bill um
has the ability to uh address some of
the concerns that this this
subcommittee yes I can give you copies
I'm so
sorry um okay and does anyone else need
so does anyone else need this
preliminary draft I believe I gave it to
representative Kenny
yes um do you have another one yes of
course sorry about
that
okay sorry about that Madam sure go
right ahead I'm sorry to interrupt no
that was my my F so um when we're
looking at the program I took into
consideration the subcommittee's um
thoughts and listened very intently I
know that this this body has had a a lot
of um focus and energy on this program
and wanting to make sure that we had
something that we felt could stand up um
to any sort of entity that comes uh
through an RFP process and seeks to
standup uh recycling stewardship program
so I wanted to take folks through um
generally the organization of it um the
paint stewardship program starts to
Define things through 149 M um one of
the pieces of information that is on
page I believe it's five if we're
looking at things it's
uh starts with let me double since I
don't have it two one two three four yes
five um we have 149 M proposals to
establish a p stewardship program at the
very bottom um section one it says any
producer representative organization
that wishes to become a stewardship
organization shall um by um January 1
2024 thank you five submit a plan for
the establishment of paint stewardship
program for the Department for approval
together with a non-refundable
application fee specified in paragraph
three below and also establish rules I
have stitched together various iter
ations of the bill and some of them had
an initial application fee listed inside
the text of the bill but I felt like
that was a better conversation for rules
to establish the fee structure um we had
talked about that we've seen that in
many other circumstances where um rules
establishes those types of fees on the
very next page at the top in um section
two um this talks about a retailer or
political subdivision and that was this
was our conversation on the Maze and the
shs about participation versus
collecting a fee and what our our
general consensus was and um the
statement says that a retailer or
political sub uh subdivision May
participate in being a collection site
but paint manufacturers shall
participate in the paint stewardship
program and fees Associated uh within
the state of New Hampshire to ensure the
paint stewardship program remains viable
for years to come so in the event that
they do not want to be a collection site
they if they sell certain brands of
paint they still still must collect um
through the manufacturers um fees that
are established on the paint prior to
sale that still must be collected to
ensure that when folks are then going to
any other site that is available that
that money is there for the program to
run um then just a little bit further
down under that section it also talks
about um a radius um 25 miles seemed to
be the conversation that we were having
around around um a permanent collection
Point whether it's a municipality that
stands one up or a retailer that stands
one up there should be one within a 25
mile radius throughout the
state the next page on subsection
four um at the very top says that a
non-refundable application fee shall be
paid by the applicant to review the
paint stewardship plan again it just
Reen numerates the fact that the fee
structure should be determined in
rules um
the very next page we talk about um 1A
where it starts with the text the
original assessment shall not uh shall
shall not be more than $3.50 for cans
above one gallon and no less than 75
cents for quantities less than or equal
to one pint so this was addressing some
of the conversation around um fee
structures being um adjusted in other
states I will also note that in uh
within this bill we also have a
requirement that annually the fee
structure should be Revisited so that we
do not have a circumstance that comes
upon us where um we need to do that
because the fees had not been
re-evaluated in some time or anything
like that so every year um that fee
structure should get looked at to make
sure that that is keeping up with what
is
necessary uh the next page I don't
really have uh anything of like major
note H same with the following page and
then we go to
um two pages uh afterwards it says where
Financial Assurance is required there's
a subsection six above that I don't know
if folks are there um paint received at
a collection location shall be
considered universal waste this is
something that we heard from the
Department that they had concerned over
hazardous waste um versus universal
waste and um I think I have the correct
um environmental statute there and it
says nothing in this section shall
otherwise reclassify paint as uh
Universal waste elsewhere in the statute
this strictly applies to the re the
places that receive the paint uh for
drop off locations anything else um
would stay as it should be um with the
classifications for hazardous waste
materials
um the following page there's nothing of
major consideration um
that we didn't really discuss I the
other portion of this conversation I
think we had just wanted to make sure
that if for some reason an entity seeks
to exist any longer and is no longer
um operating under uh the program that
there is an opportunity that um um there
are notifications to the state and
there's an ability to recoup any funds
owed to the state or um with regard to
the um those fees so there's like sort
of an um requirement for fiscal
oversight and management and assurity
that those things are being met other
than that I think that we have addressed
by and large the things that we had
talked about the other um
small um change was was with regard
to when we looked at I I just want to
continue on so
one Beyond page six we're looking at one
two
three three pages past that
subsection six it's um subsection H an
evaluation of the effectiveness of paint
stewardship
programs okay so in this conversation is
regarding Trade Secrets and proprietary
information by a
manufacturer um that information is
there to make sure that uh their
interests are also protected I mean
because the paint is reclassified so
there's antitrust carve outs and things
like that however there have been new
EPA regulations with regard to um
certain classes of chemicals not being
considered proprietary information and
so long as that regulation um comp with
EPA regulations I think that that um
that should stand the way it should be
and with that that that's
it hey does anybody have any questions
representative kalk thank you madam
chair um just a couple questions uh let
me just get to the page on when we're
talking about any producer
representative that wishes to become a
the stewardship organization shall by
January 1 submit a plan
um what happens if someone decides after
that date that they want to be part of
the program um is there anything in here
that um talks about
that thank you so this would open up a
uh an opportunity for applications for
the the plan and then the department
will then review certain plans so there
will be an opportunity establishing
rules for them to set a window for when
they receive those and when the last
date is for the for that uh the plans to
be received by um and that is in January
and then the goal would be to give
entities a full calendar year to get up
to speed before the program would launch
so follow thank you madam chair um
another question is is we have in couple
sections about non-refundable
application fees but there is no limit
on what we're going to charart I mean I
understand it's going to be done on
rules but if we make it
honorous then people won't sign up for
it so I just want to be cautious of that
also
um and may I sure follow thank thank you
madam chair um the other thing is is uh
where we talk about the original
assessment shall not be more than 350
for cans above 1 gallon and no less than
75 cents for quantity less than or equal
to one pint do we have a not not more
than for those smaller quantities or
we're just setting that saying it can't
be less than 75 cents that's correct I
feel like at at that point we're getting
into 75 cents is not that much of a you
know whether it's half a pint or a pint
I think that that's probably sufficient
and if it needs adjusted as the statute
notes um they can do that adjustment and
there is also a provision that they can
go through Jael car to request
adjustments
okay
um representative kraton has a
question uh thank you madam chair
actually just a comment U as someone who
uses a ton of different paints and stuff
like that I think this is a welcome bill
and if you look at the the fee of
basically a buck a gallon or whatever
whatever they come up with in my man
that's a a fee that's on me I buy the
paint I use the paint I should dispose
of the paint uh today there's no easy
way to do it and from what we heard in
testimony and and what I've read this
this makes that possible in an
environmentally sound way and so I I
commend um representative Murray on her
work uh with the amendment that I think
answers a lot of the questions from last
week thank you represent Bixby so I
think that um representative Murray has
done an amazing job on this and uh the
uh and we uh it it is still coming is
still being you know getting through the
end of the process at um at ol I hope
it's might be upstairs and printed at
this point but uh it is conceivable that
OMS might have made a couple of uh
typographical errors in the process of
of of doing this and we're going to be
doing a proof reading this week to make
sure that that any type of graphical
errors get noted uh if they are of no
significant importance in terms of the
content then that's the sort of thing
that can be ironed out in the Senate uh
or even in uh the enrolled bills process
um but um so we we will be doing a proof
reading of the bill before it actually
comes to the floor uh and um to make
sure that there there are no clerical
errors that need to be addressed uh but
uh I think that what we have before us
here really is the core of uh the
content and I think that um I think that
uh representative Murray has done a
really good job of putting this together
uh and I think that's something we need
to go forward with representative kto
thank you madam chair and I also will
Echo uh represent Bigby's praise for
representing Mar really taking the lead
on this I think this is an important
program um I do have one last question
though on regarding retailers and I want
to make sure I understand this if a
retailer buys paint before the start of
this program they're not going to have
to worry about the fees on that existing
paint order is that correct because it's
going to be on the
manufacturer so um they won't be
prohibited from selling that paint in
the state is that correct correct so
when it goes into effect that's when
those fees will start um and that's why
we're giving this a year to like ramp up
so that folks have time to adjust
apply signage in their um in their
establishments and have clear direction
from an entity on on what it is that
they're actually um going to let folks
know again like I said there's no fee
collections um at the register and there
are no fees uh being collected at the
depositing site so and I think we had
some conversation around Legacy paint um
my feeling is that Legacy paint will um
ultimately probably arrive at those
locations but it will quickly phase
itself out as a you know Aunt Sally's
under cabinet is being cleaned out and
being brought into in and I think that
that is um the desire is to see um that
any future paint sales has something
like this to keep it out of landfilling
and also then to keep um these items
from being poured into you know whether
it's kitty litter or any any other type
of thing um and keeping our environment
as clean as possible
representative sofikitis I also want to
thank uh representative Murray for her
leadership on
this yes I I I want to thank you
representative Murray for all your
diligence and hard work on this in your
subcommittee as well um this is a really
a really good piece of legislation as
far as I can see and in so far as if you
know typographically if there's
something missing or whatever I mean I
plan to
um once we get the uh
Amendment uh for the exec session I plan
to vote for the amendment and you know
we just so the committee knows we did
have a bill that passed out of our
committee that didn't have that OS had
omitted the effective date from uh one
of our bills and I had to have it fixed
in ways and means when it when it went
to the second committee so I mean it's
not like we haven't had that happen to
us with a typographical error or an
Omission but um overall this bill is uh
I think it's ready to go so thank you
very much for all your work on that does
anybody else have any other comments on
this bill I'm going to um end our work
session at this time and um we can
convene in another two minutes or so um
and thank you all for taking the time to
go over these two bills this morning
that we will be executing
shortly
e
my
very sensible
[Music]
I
we wait
for
basket
windix
okay GNA ask our committee members to
take their seats please
oh
okay
everyone we'll get underway with our
exec session our first bill that we are
going to uh consider for executive
session is HB
1574 removing regulations on the direct
sale of raw milk to
Consumers um do I hear a motion for that
bill representative Duty uh yes thank
you Madame chair uh I would like to move
itl on hb1 1574
dfn do I hear a second representative
Kenny um I'll second that thank you
representative Duty would you like to
speak to your motion please uh yes I
believe it was in the last year or two
that we heard a bill very similar to
this uh and I think at that time uh we
did increase um the amount of raw mil
that could be sold to Consumers so I
think um because enough time has not
passed for us to see how that bill uh
plays out in um in the retail the
consumer Market uh I believe we should
itl this bill
any other further discussion
representative
Bixby so over the last uh decade or so
we've had a number of bills dealing with
raw milk um and uh there are currently
two ways that raw milk is dealt with
with in the state one is through Farms
that are inspected and certified by the
state and that can be a larger amount
than 20 gallons or or uh and uh there
and then there are operations that are
very small and uh can produce up to 20
gallons and can produce ice cream in
quantities no larger than uh a uh 6
ounce serving the reasons for those are
were worked out um by a former member of
this committee who was in the dairy
industry for uh many decades and uh I
think that his expertise on helping
craft the what we currently have uh has
been a has been really good and I think
that we don't need to change what we
have
now represent kraton yeah thank you
madam chair I I agree with the the I
motion the thing that really struck out
to me and testimony was 150 times risk
to health issues associated with this
bill as as per uh DHHS that really
struck home so I I agree with the itl
motion thank you
okay representative ktoa thank you madam
chair
um this bill just
eliminated any amount uh restrictions
and um we need to be very cautious
because um we have some really great raw
milk legislation in this state actually
I believe we were one of the leaders at
a time when uh people were fearful of
raw milk
and um we the farmers can take that 20
gallons and can
produce uh hard cheese butter kefir all
types of products with that on a daily
basis so I think um and we need to be
cognizant that we want to make sure that
we keep our freedoms um I would not have
been imposed to a small incremental
increase but to have no restrictions uh
would not be in the best interest of
Public
Health I yeah representative Penza and
then
ger yeah I being new I just think it it
makes the most sense
um how things have been progressed and
that we let this settle for the
legislation that just passed either last
year or the year before um and have
incremental changes as you know
let this settle um before just kind of
wiping out all restrictions so um I yeah
I think this is premature representative
gerana thank you madam chair uh I think
that representative ktoa made an
excellent point I think that that the
legislation that has been enacted has
been very good it's been very good for
the state and for our farmers and
there's a chance of you know legislation
kind of going too far and reversing some
of that if we have some issues so uh I
also think that an incremental approach
is a but as you said I wanted to Second
representative comtois point that what
we have done has worked really really
well and it's important that we don't
take any steps backwards so thank you
thank you and I Echo those sentiments as
well I think you know what we we have
the most liberal um raw milk uh
production I think in the nation is what
I had heard and um I I do think that uh
some of the the restrictions that we
have put in place in the past um really
have to do with risk management and I
think we've done it pretty well and
seeing how um how the how it works um
and we haven't really seen any of the
farmers uh protesting that they want
bigger you know less restriction or
whatever um they seem to have um settled
in on this pretty well and and are are
selling their raw milk products um and
so I I'm absolutely uh for it Ling this
bill because I don't see any need really
to lift entirely lift the restrictions
that we've put in place in the
past so if there's any no other
discussion on this bill I would uh ask
that the clerk call the role please
thank you madam chair and the motion is
itl on hb1 1574 representative kraton I
representative coma yes representative
Phillips yes represent Nelson yes
represent Sidell yes represent kahill
yes represent Kenny yes represent Penza
yes represent smart represent Bixby yes
represent sopus yes represent Duty yes
represent
Murray yes represent jamana yes
represent H Haskins I represent
Howard represent NAB yes represent Morse
yes represent bman yes madame chair yes
20 shall It Go on consent seeing no
objection ction yes should it should be
on consent and I will close out the
exact for hb1
1574 and
I
okay sure I
want
um why don't
we you w to go ahead and yeah what
whatever you think would be the
best why don't we when why doesn't she
go when we are at that point Point okay
okay all right um I'm going to open up
the exec for HB 1698 relative to the use
of drones for the aerial application of
pesticides and I would like to move um
OTP for
Amendment adopt the amendment I'm sorry
adopt the amendment um 202 24- 11147
H for uh HB
and I will second I see representative
Bixby seconding that thank you very much
and I'll speak to my Amendment which we
had discussed earlier um the amendment
to this bill uh points to uh RSA 422
colon
3 uh Roman numeral Roman numeral 30
which um defines what unmanned aircraft
means uh which points to the federal
definition of unmanned aircraft
uh and that uh the amendment also
changes the height at which um spraying
can occur uh it may not exceed 20 feet
above ground level any discussion on
this amendment representative
kraton uh yes ma'am um this amendment
answered the questions that I had uh one
the height in fact reduces the amount of
uh wind impact and spray over um
especially because the Drone pushes the
pesticide down whereas if you're going
from the from the ground is going up and
getting more into the atmosphere and
there's more spread and then the other
thing to discussion we had with rep
Penza that I think is important is the
application of this drone um pesticide
is by professionally licensed folks and
so most of these um Farms that are using
this technique are
Contracting licensed professionals if
they're doing it by themselves and they
are in fact licensed professionals so I
I think uh again great work working with
folks to overcome some of the issues
that we found last week and I will be
voting OTP on this amendment represent
Bixby yeah so the amendment addresses uh
a couple of things one is the uh the
spray height which in the original bill
was 5050 feet this drops it to 20 feet
that uh is a a great Improvement uh the
other is that it cites uh the
appropriate other statutes uh that are
that govern uh aerial spraying uh and it
allows for drones that are greater than
55 pounds uh and those drones have not
only uh so there there are pesticide
regulations at the state level and then
there are uh pilot regulations at the
federal level
so uh the um the so the one needs to be
licensed not only as a pesticide
applicator but also as a drone drone
pilot in order to be able to do this
work uh that's typically going to be as
representative Katon said a contractor
although a farmer could in fact you get
all those licensing if if he or she
chose to
so I think this is a really great bill
and we should just pass
it
okay all right and any other
discussion um representive kto thank you
madam chair um and I'd like to thank you
uh for working on this uh this will be a
huge win for agriculture in New
Hampshire not only will it help um with
really targeting where the pesticides go
uh but will also help um um with
overspray and I think we'll see a
reduction in pesticides through use of
drones and it will also help reduce the
capital outlay that Farms have to uh
make if they utilize these drone
operators thank
you seeing no other uh discussion for
this bill um this amendment I would ask
the clerk to call the role for uh
adoption of this amendment thank you
madam chair and we're adopting Amendment
202 2 41147 H representative kraton hi
representative ktoa yes representative
Phillips yes representative Nelson yes
represent sidel yes represent kahill yes
represent Kenny yes represent Penza yes
represent smart represent Bixby yes
represent sopus yes represent datsi yes
represent Murray yes represent Jama yes
represent H Haskins I represent Howard
represent NAB yes yes represent moris
yes represent ban yes madame chair oh
yes amendment is adopted 20 thank you
with the uh adopted amendment I would
like to move uh a to pass
ltpa uh hear a second from
representative pix thank you we'll
second that and uh speak to my uh motion
is well we've said it all I think and I
think we can go ahead and uh call the
roll on this as well
thank you madam chair the motion is
otpa representative kraton I represent
ktoa yes represent Phillips yes
represent Nelson yes represent cidel yes
represent kahill yes represent Kenny
represent Penza yes represent smart
represent Bixby yes represent sopus yes
represent Duty yes represent Murray yes
represent jamna yes represent H Haskins
I represent Howard yes represent NAB yes
represent
moris yes represent bamen yes Madam
chair yes 20 shall It Go on consent
seeing no objection yes thank you I'm
going to call uh HB 1698 closed and open
up the exec for HB
1703 relative to the sale of kangaroo
and Caribou meat do I hear a
motion yes' representative Katon I rep
uh I recommend itl do I hear a second
representative NAB I second the motion
thank you representative kraton would
you like to speak to your motion yeah
yes Madam chair the the
overwhelming argument uh that pushed me
to itl was the fear and the threat to
carbon wasting disease in in the state
of New Hampshire uh we heard testimony
that that was not a problem right now
but that could be a significant problem
bringing Carib in uh even if you Fen the
Caribou uh appropriately that doesn't
mean they couldn't get out or that the
disease could not be brought into the
state and I think that the risk of
chronic wasting disease to the state
overwhelms the desire to uh commercially
grow kangaroo or Caribou meat in the
state over okay any other comment on
that itl motion representative Bixby I
think that representative cron covered
it pretty well okay thank you um if
there's no other discussion I would like
to have the clerk call the role thank
you madam chair the motion is itl and HB
1703 represent kraton I represent ktoa
yes represent Phillips yes represent
Nelson yes represent sidel yes represent
kahill yes represent Kenny yes represent
Penza yes represent smart represent
Bixby yes represent sopus yes represent
Duty yes represent Murray yes represent
Jama yes represent H Haskins I represent
Howard represent NAB yes represent Morse
yes bam men yes madame chair yes 20
shall It Go and consent seeing no
objection
yes put that on consent and I close the
ex for HB
1703 and I open up the exec session for
HB
1145 prohibiting the private ownership
of landfills and I would like to make
the motion of
itl do I hear a second representative
Katon ma'am I second that motion okay um
I will speak to my motion then um I
believe that um this bill should be ited
simply
because there is nothing prohib hibiting
the state right now from opening a
landfill and um prohibiting private
ownership I I certainly have problems
with um prohibiting private ownership of
anything
um but this this bill is meant to deal
with the issue of out of state trash and
the amount of out ofate trash that comes
into New
Hampshire um
well I believe this bill is
well-intentioned I just don't see that
um this is a necessary thing to do
simply because as I stated before the
state has full ability right now to open
up uh a landfill and um that's all I
would have to say and I welcome any
other comments representative Bixby so
um the the issue the the core issue with
it is in fact out ofate trash
and the problem with out ofate trash is
that uh the state does not have the
authority to uh fully regulate out ofate
trash uh from or or can't can't regulate
out ofate trash any differently than
instate trash uh because of the um
interstate commerce clause in the
Constitution and that means that we
can't do things that would prohibit
putting out ofate trash into our
landfills uh unless we had that those
same prohibitions on instate trash uh
which this really constrains our ability
to control what sort of out ofate trash
we is coming in it also um uh the the
interstate commerce clause also indicate
would say that we can't charge diff
differential rates for out ofate out
ofate trash and in state trash we can't
uh make exclusions on particular types
of outer State trash if we put those if
if any of that um sort of trash is put
into landfills from instate
sources uh by making by requiring that
new landfills be publicly owned and that
could be either at the state level or at
a county or Min Municipal level uh that
would give us the power to say
that uh the uh we could we would be able
to charge differential rates for out of
state in and inate trash at a publicly
owned landfill we would be able to say
there are certain things that we will
not accept from out of state in a public
landfill we would be able to say that uh
we can put a cap of you know any amount
that we any any a cap of any severity or
or strength on on the total amount of
out ofate trash coming in so that uh it
really gives us a whole lot more control
in terms of how this works with um with
uh business uh the bill actually says
that the that if it's a state-owned
landfill it would have to be operated by
a uh a private uh um company that would
be hired uh through the full RFP process
to manage that landfill uh
and this is actually some so across the
country uh roughly half of the landfills
that are operating across the country
right now are publicly owned and the
ones of those that are uh most
successful are the ones that are using a
pro public private man uh partnership
like uh what this bill would create so I
think that um this is really way of
helping New Hampshire take control of
what trash comes into the state and how
it's dealt
with representative kto thank you madam
chair and although I understand with rep
what representative Bixby is trying to
say we do not currently prohibit that in
statute we also know that we have
municipalities that have their own
landfills and do prohibit trash from out
ofate and can dictate
currently um what is taken in um and
then we have
Cooperative St places that have that
also so there is nothing
prohibiting the publicly owned landfills
now
so if a county or municipality thinks
that this is an important
issue they can take this up on their own
without
legislation representative ger
thank you madam chair uh representative
Bixby hit a lot of the points that I
wanted to hit this is the one bill
dealing with out estate waste that
allows us to do several things I won't
go over them again as representative
Bixby has already explained it well also
the point that this is not Reinventing
the wheel more than half of the
landfills in the United States today
including several in states around us
here in New England are uh publicly
owned uh and of course some we have here
in New Hampshire uh there are two points
that I I want to emphasize
um one in response to the to the point
which is well taken the representative
comad just made about there's nothing in
legislation Madam chair made this point
before that would prohibit the state
from doing this now the fact of the
matter is we will not need more than one
landfill in the state especially if we
get our act together on some of our
reduction goals which I'm skeptical
about but even with the track that we're
currently on we're not going to need
more than one landfill in this state for
the next Century for the rest of this
Century if if private companies are
allowed to continue to open landfills in
the state it's not about need it's about
profit it's about being able to continue
to take unlimited outof State waste if
we're looking at one more landfill in
the state of New Hampshire to get us
through the rest of the 21st century it
shouldn't be a private landfill that can
take as much out of state waste as it
wants to uh as they want to it should be
a publicly owned and privately operated
if it's if it's state ownership entity
that can give us the benefits that
representative Bixby referred to before
and I want to reiterate a point that I
made when we heard the bill in the first
place was that we're talking about the
public expense here I think it is clear
uh if any of us asked our constituents
how they feel about being The Dumping
Ground of waste from all over New
England I think that where they stand on
that is pretty clear I think what our
duty in terms of representing their
wishes is also pretty clear and I think
if we asked them uh our con consents
across the state if they would be
willing to take that hit per person on
their taxes in order to buy the land in
order to assure that we will not be The
Dumping Ground for out ofate waste in
perpetuity I'm confident that that our
constituents on either side of the aisle
uh would absolutely support that in a
heartbeat so uh for all of those reasons
I think that this is the right direction
for us to go uh so I I also want to
point out
that with the study committee for out of
state waste at least when we produced
the report we had support from all
members of that committee that was three
Republicans and one Democrat and we all
supported that when we approved the
final report uh we also have bipartisan
support as you can see on the
sponsorship including bipartisan support
on this committee I want to thank
representative Penza who has worked on
uh these issues regarding out ofate
trash so uh I think that this is an
issue that we can get bipartisan support
for uh on the floor and I have
absolutely no question that it has broad
support across the state thank you
representative kraton and then
representative Morris thank you madam
chair yeah I I'm not as confident as my
neighbor here about uh everyone in this
state willing to pay the additional cost
I I'm not uh the other thing is this
bill I think limits options to the state
in terms of if there is only one to make
it the most effective the most efficient
and the safest it can be I think we
should look at all options whether it's
public or private if we pass this bill
then that takes options off the table
that could make it more safe more
efficient and more effective over thank
you representative Morris thank you um I
just would like to sort of second um a
lot of the comments that were made by
representative gerna um and I I
understand the hesitation to limit
private ownership of businesses and
respect that position however I do think
that when it comes down to public health
and safety we need to make sure that we
are being very careful about making sure
that that's going to be regulated to the
best of our abilities so that we don't
continue to see New Hampshire um you
know be number one for different types
of cancer in New England and you know so
many health concerns that that we see on
the rise here largely due to um seeing
all of this out ofate trash come into
our communities and and cause further
concerns for our environment and our
constituents than you okay
representative
Penza yeah I just wanted to reiterate or
ditto um so much of what representative
J said I think the clear piece here is
that it it's not just it's a public
private partnership because it's not
just eliminating private
and it's need-based I I think that's the
most important thing here we do we
really want a private company just you
know buying up land to put a landfill in
if there's no need it it just doesn't
seem to make sense this isn't a a person
coming in here and Manufacturing widgets
we're talking about trash and we're
talking about environmental impact we're
talking about the health and safety of
all our New Hampshire citizens I think
this is a good balance um I very much
support the bill and uh that's it thank
you any other representative sofikitis
and the representative H
Haskins we have found in these years
since um I've been on this committee
that um it was a business model to find
towns that were
unzoned and um to have a private company
come in and say that we that this area
needs a landfill and that um they would
set people in these small towns against
each other by business practices and it
was very distressing for me to see um
when I go around when I would go around
I would see and ask about the capacity
and and people would say at the
landfills oh we have a 40-year capacity
or we have a 50 60 that's a lot of years
and um
so people were being told that that we
need these landfills and they don't need
them and then what they were doing is
just bringing trash from out of state so
something to increase knowledge I think
that getting people to start
understanding that um we all make Trash
that's for sure but we um we can dispose
of it smartly and that we don't need to
uh pollute or uh for lack of a better
word rape our environment to um to put
these these um
huge landfills in our most pristine and
lovely places so I um I think this is a
wonderful Bill and I'm glad to support
it thank you representative H Haskins
thank you madam chair we heard very
compelling testimony about this bill we
had 311 people sign in in support we
have a trash problem in the state I
think a public private partnership is
one of the ways we can attack that
problem um people have talked about the
environmental impacts some 38 years ago
it was decided that we needed private
landfills and now we have come to the
point where we understand we need local
control local control is a very popular
Topic in the house so I think that will
augur in our favor with this bill I
think it's timely I think we need it and
I hope people will support it thank
you okay any other
comments being none um when you uh
register your vote I'd appreciate you
putting on your make sure you put your
microphone on um getting an email saying
that people can't be heard heard with
their votes and I don't want your vote
to be missed um so I would ask now that
the um clerk call the rooll on this
thank motion thank you madam chair the
motion is itl representative kraton I
representative ktoa yes representative
Phillips yes represent Nelson yes
represent Sidell yes represent kahill
yes represent Kenny yes represent Penza
no represent
smart yes
representative Bixby no represent
siketus no represent Duty no represent
Murray no represent Jama no represent H
Haskins no represent Howard no represent
NAB no represent Morris no represent ban
no Madam chair
yes vote is 9 to 11 the motion
fails
do I hear a motion representative Bixby
Madam chair I'd like to uh moot move OTP
on um HB
1145 do I hear a second representative
ger you would you like to speak to your
motion I believe that we've pretty much
covered the discussion so let's just
take a vote all right um if there's no
other comments to be made I would ask
the clerk to please call the role on uh
OTP motion for HB
1145 thank you madam chair the motion is
OTP represent kraton nay represent coma
no represent Phillips no represent
Nelson no represent cidel no represent
kahill no represent Kenny no represent
Penza yes represent
smart no representative Bixby yes
representative sopus yes represent Duty
yes represent Murray yes represent Jam
yes represent H Haskins yes
represent Howard yes represent NAB yes
represent Morris yes represent baman yes
madame
chair um on OTP no okay
119 motion
passes okay
um
guess is anyone going to write a
Minority Report I will write The
Minority Report thank
you okay I'm going to close out the
exact for HB
1145 and open up the exact for hb1
1632 relative to outof State waste and
do I hear a motion representative gerana
thank you madam chair I move OTP on HB
1632 and I will second that and
representative ger would you like to
speak to your motion thank you madam
chair yes this is another approach that
came out of the study committee on out
of state waste uh we heard testimony
from the Attorney General's office that
uh there are ways regarding that that we
can in effect challenge the interstate
commerce clause if we can demonstrate uh
that there are sufficient needs in this
case the argument would be we're talking
about an impact on public resources the
land the air the water are public
resources and uh given the capacity that
we have to meet the needs of instate
waste um that it is in the public
interest of the people of the State of
New Hampshire to be able to restrict the
amount that uh we get from out of state
that will be a challenge to the
interstate commerce clause it I suspect
will likely be uh the subject of some uh
legal consideration but uh as I said the
the recommendation for this legislation
came out of that discussion with the
attorney General's office and uh and I
think that this is definitely a worthy
um effort on our part to uh limit that
out of state waste from coming in so I
hope folks will support the motion
representative kraton thank you madam
chair I I agree completely that it's a
worthy
effort uh I will be voting
OTP I do have a concern that that has
been I've just discussed at length with
several folks and I still have some
concern but I'm going to vote OTP my
concern is that if you're taking 35% of
the tips away from each one of these
folks that that's going to have a
significant impact on the bottom line
for those
companies that those tips uh that that
35%
will potentially be assumed by the the
current users and the instate users so
my my fear is that the cost to the
instate users will go up
and that's still a concern but I feel
that the the benefits outweigh the cost
and I'll I will vote OTP M chair
representative ger thank you madam chair
I just want to say and I hear
representative kraton's uh concerns and
and I appreciate his his support for the
bill I will say that the bill uh
grandfathers in current landfills and
and expansions of those landfills so uh
while there may down the road be an
effect uh that representative kraton was
referring to it certainly wouldn't be
for quite a long time because our
current landfills will continue to
operate under the under the rules as
they exist now so any uh any addition
will not be for sometime down the road
representative
ktoa thank you madam chair and I want to
thank uh represent Jamar for reminding
us that those the landfills are
grandfathered and are exempt for for
this
um and so I will vote OTP on this but
because we only need one more landfill
and if it is going to be a public
private ownership this bill in my
opinion is not even
needed representative Bixby yeah
so um it is
uh the um the probabilities of is
difficult to uh gauge from the votes
that we take in this committee the
probability of a bill becoming law uh
that it still needs to make it through
several several other steps so I think
that if we have two uh possible options
that increases the chance that we're
going to be able to solve the
problem representative Penza yeah I just
wanted to speak to that I think that um
giving
um of course this has to leave here and
go to the full house but giving the
other body um you know kind of an array
a menu of options um I think is a good
thing so um I fully support those as
well any other
comments seeing none I would ask the
clerk to call the role thank you madam
chair the motion is OTP on HB 1632
representative kraton I represent K yes
representative Phillips yes repr
represent Nelson yes represent sidel yes
represent kahill yes represent Kenny yes
represent Penza yes represent smart yes
represent Bixby yes represent sakas yes
represent Duty yes represent
Murray yes represent Jama yes represent
H Haskins I represent Howard yes
represent NAB yes represent Morris yes
represent Bushman yes madame chair yes
20 shall It Go on
consent yes seeing no
objection I will close out the exec for
HB 1632 and open up the exec for HB
154 um do I hear a motion representative
Murray uh thank you madam chair I'd like
to move an amendment go ahead I'd like
to move 2024
d1210 do I here a second I will second
that thank
you okay representative Murray would you
please speak to your motion uh thank you
madam chair I I not to I know we've
discussed this in the previous work
session at at length so I won't be too
long and just saying that I am extremely
grateful to everybody who worked on this
subcommittee to arrive at um and um the
initial sort of uh idea that was brought
forward before our committee to arrive
at where we are and uh not to to the
labor the point but I think that we all
recognize that um standing up a program
like this is an important step to um
achieving some of our waste hierarchy
goals and I'm really um honored to be
able to uh present the amendment for
consideration thank you any other
discussion on the amendment
representative kraton yes ma'am thank
you ma'am
uh really just great work representative
Murray I support it thank
you representative Bixby yeah I just
want to say how impressed I am with the
amount of work that representative
Murray did on this amendment I think
that um she's just done an amazing job
and I'm fully in
support I couldn't agree more absolutely
any other represent ger thank you I'll
join the chorus of of Applause uh and as
someone who served on the subcommittee
uh again uh represent representative
Murray did a fabulous job of organizing
that of leading that and doing a
tremendous amount of work so thank you
any other comment representative kill
you guys have all painted a really good
[Laughter]
uh all right awesome okay um I would
like to have the clerk call the RO on
the uh OT uh I'm sorry on the um
Amendment motion thank you madam chair
this is to adopt Amendment 20241
1210 representative kraton I
representative K yes representative
Phillips yes representative Nelson yes
represent Sidell yes represent
kahill yes represented Kenny yes
represent Penza yes represent smart yes
represent Bixby yes represent sopus yes
represent Duty yes represent
Murray yes represent Jama yes represent
H Haskins I represent Howard yes
represent NAB yes represent moris yes
represent ban yes Madam chair yes
amendment is adopted
20 okay do I hear a motion for
otpa represent Murray I'd like to make a
motion of otpa with Amendment 2024
d1210 and I will happily
second and I think we've discussed this
so uh I have the clerk call the rooll on
it thank you madam chair the motion is
otpa representative kraton I represent
ktoa yes represent Phillips yes
represent Nelson yes represent
sidel yes represent kahill yes represent
Kenny yes represent Penza yes represent
smart yes represent Bixby yes represent
sakas yes represent Duty yes represent
Murray yes represent Jama yes represent
H Haskins hi represent Howard yes
represent NAB yes represent moris yes
represent baman yes Madam chair
yes motion passes 20 shall It Go and
consent yes seeing no um objection of
course I'm going to close out
hp504 and um I would like to thank uh
representative em Emily
Phillips and I would like to thank
representative Sheila sidel and
representative Jody Nelson and
representative Tim Cahill for joining us
and sitting in as substitutes this
morning we really appreciate your
volunteering and uh uh happy to have you
on our committee this
morning um the other thing I wanted to
uh remind everybody who is uh going to
be owing me committee reports to please
get them to me as soon as possible
because our deadline to get out of this
committee is the 21st so we need to get
our committee reports in and that would
be representative
Duty myself representative kraton um
representative Bixby representative ger
and representative
Murray on
your um for this one yes no for the ones
that we've exec today we need committee
reports and um one one other
Announcement by representative kraton uh
thank you ma'am and and so the dees
Rules Committee next meeting is at 9 on
the 2nd and if we have followup
questions representative H Haskins is
putting together some I think there were
a couple others representative Murray I
think had some and repetend if we can
get those to me today then I'll get
those back out for approval and we'll
get those over to Dees by the end of the
week thank you okay I also uh
representative Bixby go ahead yeah so I
noticed that I think we have a couple of
Senate bills sort of waiting for us I
don't know if you heard anything more
about that um and I assume we'll
probably be taking those up in April I
yes I have not uh seen anything formally
yet um but we will we will begin uh
hearing those in April um I want to
remind everybody we've got a um an
invitation for April 16th 8:30 in the
morning from New Hampshire young Farmers
for their um annual young farmer
committee annual legislative breakfast
and I would ask you please to RSVP to
your invitation that you've received um
the other thing is I we are obviously
done with our house bills we went
through 42 bills I want to congratulate
you all for all your hard work and um
putting up with having to come in twice
a week for our committee meetings um
hopefully for for what we're going to be
getting from the Senate and we won't be
having that kind of schedule but um I
want to thank everybody for their
wonderful work and working together and
uh it's been a great couple of months
representative Bixby and I'd like to
thank chair Aaron for uh the great job
that she did in terms of organizing the
processing of these bills I think that
we moved through them effectively and it
was a little bit tough when we were
doing two two sessions a week but um I
think that uh the way that she put
together a a pattern of doing the
hearings doing work sessions promptly so
we could assess the bills and then doing
the exacts uh really uh move things
through very effectively thank you
representative sofikitis I just want to
thank you madam chair for your hard work
appreciate
it ah thank you
I
shs okay well um we'll see you when we
see you have a great rest of the day
enjoy it and um thanks again for
everything you guys do for for for the
your constituents and everyone in New
Hampshire thank
you
e